they are fleeing in hardy wooden boats
from a place known as the land of fear
of our swathe of northern mozambique now
ruled by
a vicious band of islamist extremists
more than half a million people have
escaped a great exodus
that's gone largely unnoticed sky news
the first international broadcaster to
gain access
how long do you think you can go on
living like this
hundreds of thousands have sought
shelter in a city called pemba
camping on the beach in tents and lean
twos
or squeezing themselves into the
impoverished neighborhoods which
cling to the coast the chotto family
shared a farm in a town called makamiya
now 40 members of the family eat and
sleep on the same dank compound
the adults are hungry the children
unwell
their skin plagued by infection
and they're traumatized by the men who
attack them
lucia says the insurgents murdered her
brother
then took her nieces away
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
at first they were dismissed as a bunch
of bandits
but the insurgents known locally as
al-shabaab
have set the region ablaze
they've captured dozens of communities
and a strategic
port and they've terrorized the region's
inhabitants
the mozambican military is struggling to
reassert control
camps for the dispossessed have sprung
up on the sweltering plains that
surround pember
but these giant constructs lack the most
basic facilities
this settlement has sprung up
haphazardly around a small
village and it's turned into a city in a
matter of a couple of months
and the living conditions here are rough
the people may be safe from the
insurgents
but that doesn't necessarily mean
they'll survive
there were dozens of people waiting for
treatment
outside a hard-pressed clinic run by msf
most were malnourished and some had
malaria
and the staff told us they were dealing
with a major outbreak of cholera
they set up a tent with special beds for
those with cholera
the night before we arrived and we found
a woman
called amina and a four-year-old called
helena
fighting for their lives
without treatment cholera can kill in a
matter of
hours she is so beautiful but i can see
that she's
very weak
[Music]
the nurse on duty did what he could then
sent her
in a 4x4 to a local treatment center
a decision that has probably saved her
life
for helena made it through the night and
regained a little of her strength
but she got sick in these camps and
she'll have to return
if she's able to complete her recovery
john sparks sky news near pember in
mozambique